[Musik]
ich melde mich hier aus karlsruhe wo
heute historisches passiert jens spahn
trifft auf eine ihm unbekannte spezies
einen armen menschen
ich wollte ihm auch mal meinen respekt
zollen
ich merke hier wird viel vom spanier
halten jetzt deine fans ein historisches
ereignis hier heute in karlsruhe die
demonstration gegen jens spahn setzt
sich jetzt in bewegung schon aufgeregt
ja natürlich
glauben sie wird tatsächlich mit ihnen
über armut reden oder wie immer nur über
sich selbst nein ich glaube ganz fest
dass er darüber redet ein bisschen zeit
mitgebracht von daher werden wir
schaffen will der kanzler werden
deswegen ja ja natürlich also dann
erkennst konstatiert dann wandert aus ja
wir fahren jetzt hier richtung jens
spahn und zwar mit der bahn
ersparen sie zu gucken das ist nennt
sich öffentliches verkehrsmittel das ist
quasi ein dienstwagen den man sich teilt
das kann sich nur noch um wenige minuten
handeln wir laufen jetzt hier hinterher
während sandra es per pedes und mit der
bahn unterwegs ist zum treffpunkt hören
wir jens spahn ist auch unterwegs
wir sind jetzt hier vor dem haus von
sandra es angekommen ein flirren liegt
in der luft jens spahn wird gleich
kommen die gesamte weltpresse hat sich
hinter mir versammelt jens spahn kommt
jetzt hier mit einer tüte ich glaube mit
abgelaufenen lebensmitteln aus der
bundestags kantine wie immer fein
gekleidet so hat spielerin ganz spannend
versucht noch den richtigen eingang er
kann die häuser nicht unterscheiden wenn
sie so nach armut aussehen klar das
kennt er nicht ist es eine neue
situation von ihnen es gibt es hier die
launige begrüßung und jetzt schließt
sich hier hinter mir die tür
und jetzt heißt es warten
ja man kann nur sagen bevor er ans
sparen die wohnung hier betreten hat
haben diese blumen noch geblüht ja liebe
zufällig kriege gerade eine noch
unbestätigte meldung rein jens spahn ist
gar nicht wegen hartz iv ihr hier
ihm gehört das haus und er spricht
gerade mit sandra es über die nächste
mieterhöhung zum nächsten ersten
ein gutes gespräch miteinander alles
gute wünsche freuen sie sich nach dieser
engen sozialwohnung so wieder auf ihren
geräumigen dienstwagen
ja das war wohl so schnell habe ich
lange nicht mehr jemanden dienstwagen
einsteigen sind ein historischer tag in
karlsruhe geht zu ende
zusammengefasst ein großer schritt für
jens spahn und ein sehr kleiner für die
menschheit zurück ins studio
[Musik]
[Applaus]